[Music]
good morning my name is rachel parker i
am senior director of research at cfar a
global research organization that
convenes extraordinary minds to address
the most important questions facing
science and humanity
it is my distinct pleasure
to introduce you to our speakers if they
could join me online
dan and david
dan resnitz professor
and monk chair of innovation studies at
the university of toronto dan is
currently serving as the clifford clark
visiting economist in the department of
finance in addition to serving as
co-director of cfar's program on
innovation equity and the future of
prosperity
and to david dodge former deputy
minister of health as well as former
governor of the bank of canada and a
long-serving member of seafire's board
of directors
today's session will last approximately
45 minutes i will be taking advantage of
my position as chair today to ask our
speakers the first question before
inviting dan and david
to ask questions to one another
the session is being recorded and will
be available on the cfar website next
week
additionally if you have any questions
that you would like to ask of our
speakers we ask that you please put
those into the q a function
and we will address those at the end
thanks very much for joining
dan david
thank you for joining this morning
uh for a first question i'd like to ask
what is the problem an innovation agenda
is trying to overcome in the canadian
context
do you want uh so i'll just thought
just to make to annoy everybody
we have several problems but the main
problem that we have right now and i
think this is the first time a
government admitted that in the last 20
something years
we have
now what's known technically as a
classic market failure in innovation
which anyone who write reads economics
innovation 101 should expect a country
to have
where the private uh business for
completely rational reasons
invest less and less in innovation and
even in new technologies
in canada just to put it into
perspective uh we are the only
uh oecd and g7 country where
business investment in r d have been
going down annually year after year
uh we are now below poland just to put
it in perspective
and one of the
slowest private business sector to
engage with new technologies in the g7
you can also see it in our productivity
we are also using our human capital
really wastefully
and even worse if you look at what has
happened actually for because of really
good public policy for the last 30 years
we now have the human capital the most
educated workforce in the world
we have one of the best research
infrastructure in the world
uh maybe the best university system you
know bang for the dollar in the world
all of that has happened in the last 30
years while our businesses have gone
less and less sophisticated
and that has led to even worse
stagnation of a median wage so
basically who got hurt is a middle class
than almost all our peers
including we we tell ourselves this
legend that canadian are more relaxed
than american and other in the g7 you
look at the hours canadian work and how
much time they spend in their family
it's actually worse than most of our
peers partly because the median wages
have been stagnant for so long so in
order to keep welfare
the only way to solve it
and the only way for our children to
have a better future and
have a green economy which is by
definition engaging with new technology
is to fix this market fail
and that i think is the
a very complex problem because once
you're engaged with this business
behavior and business model for over 20
years
this is a vicious problem to solve but
you know like we say on all difficult
problems and various addictions the
first step is to admit that you have a
problem
well maybe i can pitch in here
uh i've been around this game for a long
time at the department of finance for
many years
um
and
uh you know going all the way back to
the lemon tang report which is over 50
years ago
we've we've had various reports
uh from time to time the most
recent one i guess three or four years
ago from max blau uh
wrote it
detailing um the failure
of business investment
and not not just business investment in
r d
but indeed in the last 10 years we've
had
an aggregate failure in business
investment
period
we've been concentrating and investing
in housing and we've stopped investing
in productive uh in productive capital
so we have a we have a long long
standing problem
um one that
perhaps there was a period where it
didn't appear so severe
when when we had a couple of real
innovative leaders
uh
in the field
um
and
business business leaders uh i would say
who were innovative the walder lights of
the world uh
led to giving us a nortel and uh that's
been off blackberry so we did have some
business
uh innovative uh
invention uh
in that sense um
but in the last uh decade uh that
too has or that has completely
uh fallen away
uh and so
dan is absolutely right
uh the problem is not in the university
sector or if you will the
innovative research sector that
that cfar is
so engaged in the problem
is in
uh at the business level and the
question is
is that because the genetic makeup of
our business leaders is somehow
different
uh
than that of
business leaders south of the border
or is there something in the canadian
policy framework
that we have both federal and provincial
uh frameworks
that militates against business uh
doing what it really really needs
needs to do
and i gotta say dan i thought that one
of the great
features about
your book on innovation is that you put
the emphasis
not on governments but on the innovators
themselves whether that they be business
leaders or whether they be
inventors and and researchers
thank you
um
rachel do do do we want to have
questions how do you want to run just so
i'll know otherwise i'll start torturing
david
i think that's happening to me
i'm more than happy to ask an additional
question though if you if you don't mind
sure
[Music]
so i'm i'm curious dan and this
draws a bit on on your book but also um
some of the interviews that you've been
doing uh most recently as well is is the
issue in your view
one of productivity or one of idea
creation
well i think the issue is is on i'll
i'll
slightly break it apart
but it's not definitely not ideas
creation so
um canadian actually have been amazing
in coming up with new ideas um seafront
know its best as a matter of fact safer
have backed canadian for a thing we now
call artificial intelligence deep
learning when nobody else did
the problem is that it's not clear that
canada as a country as a community
would actually enjoy the productivity
gains the new businesses the jobs from
that invention
and that has been a reoccurring theme
and has been as david says a recurring
theme for a very long time to put it in
perspective how long
uh as in as new canadians we give them a
booklet of about 21 pages where they're
supposed to read and pass an exam
and there's a very short chapter on
innovation there
one of the people or two of the people
they have to learn as canadian heroes
are people that invented the light bulb
had a patent and then sold it to edison
and we all know what edison did with the
light bulb
nobody knows that the two canadians
invented it
nothing was gained for canada from bad
invention
general electric is not a canadian
company
and that has been the problem again and
again and again
and that's something that we need to
change
i would also say that in the case of
canada
it's not just the new ge's
it's not just you know new companies and
new technologies
we are a resource rich very diverse very
big country but even in those industries
we are now declining in sophistication
and when we look at our peers and our
peers shouldn't be
should be in the g7 or at least the oecd
when we look at countries that were in a
similar stage and a similar relationship
of trade with a great power
what they have done
and very successfully by changing the
policy framework
is to make over industries innovative
so they employ different kind of skills
and the greatest example that we did we
now do the research in finance and look
at other examples and after we identify
the problem finland this one
and if you look at finland forestry
industry you know we canadian are
constantly
going to the american and
fight about soft wood
the fiends understood that this is a
dead end to fight on softwood instead
they completely and utterly revamp the
pulp and paper and forestry industry and
it's now not only one of the most
innovative in the world but all the
equipment to that industry
uh is made in finland that industry
looked like what we now call industry
4.0 in 2000
uh this is where canada should be
this is where is our competitive
advantage not necessarily trying to
compete with silicon valley
then you you mentioned the forestry
sector which is a classic uh classic one
where
we had an advantage and have not uh
capitalized on it
to what extent do you think that is
policy or needs
does that
come from
somehow the
uh
the people and the industrial
organizations
um
themselves is is there
something
missing there or
did we have a policy framework that was
dead wrong
so let's start with the people
i would have believed that it's the
people if it won't be so many
extremely successful canadian
that when they wanted to innovate based
on their invention or just to innovate
they moved to the u.s
and immediately become unbelievably
successful and they're still doing that
so i find it strange
to claim that it's something engrained
in our culture and our genes but then we
move to a different policy framework
which is actually very similar and very
close to us
you know just south of a border and
suddenly all canadians behave
differently so it must be something
within the framework incumbent
it also um
must be
and what we haven't done in innovation
is understanding where the risk and
uncertainty are too high
for private that without our direct
intervention let's call it fixing that
market failure
we should not expect businesses uh or
individuals to innovate or even engage
with new technologies
and especially where that happens where
you can actually make quite a lot of
profits and have profit margins
because of commodity booms because of
relationship with the us
because of multiple things um
where
if we don't do that it's actually
doubly rational in canada not
necessarily in somewhere else to
actually lower the sophistication of
what we do in this country because you
can have higher profit at the lower risk
and forestry is one the oil industry
especially in one province is another
and we can go on and on and on uh other
countries think about forestry or
agriculture and again think about
finland or even the us
understood
that you cannot expect
those companies or the farmers to
actually be the agents of innovation
and you need to coordinate all of that
innovation so it will have a systemic
effect right that you would not expect
one company to completely change the
whole forestry industry
we have done that but only for a very
very short period of time in order to
solve one problem and then after we got
off experience of how doing that we said
great now let's retire
for example canola
we have never created that again and
again we have never admitted that we
have regulatory problems
we have never really admitted uh a part
of course in rhetorics that for a
company in alberta for example it's much
easier to export to the us than to the
rest of canada
and i use the word export on purpose
in that system you should expect
business leaders to be completely
rational when they try to maximize
profit but not just maximize profit as
you know david they want to maximize
profit at the lowest risk and
uncertainty and that's exactly what they
have done
the problem is the long-term impact on
our community
[Music]
and now we are sort of stuck in that you
know equilibrium and we have to change
it and we should not expect the business
to change it by themselves
uh it's a part especially since unlike
other countries and again i'll use
finland israel we can think about other
we don't have a massive crisis we have a
slow decline if you want to be
very worried about canada we are the
proverbial frog
which is slowly cooking but we don't
even understand we are being boiled
alive
well maybe maybe uh the minister's words
in the budget uh are a recognition of
that
uh but
still
the issue is
what are the policy levers
that uh
that
deal with the pro
not unless they deal with the problem
that provide the incentive for
individuals and businesses to deal with
the problem
um
and so
the classic
you're at the department of finance now
the classic one we
have worried about for a long time
is
have we got a tax system
that is
favorable to invention or
or not well
you know we have tried over the years in
fact if you look at it simply at
statutory rates uh we've done incredibly
well and the better we do
with the oecd's darling in many ways in
that regard
um the better we do the worse we perform
so
maybe that is not
not the heart of the issue
um
another issue that you mentioned and i'd
like your comment further on is
regulation
uh
certainly from a business perspective of
business criticism
is that our regulations are
ever-changing uh the
business can't take the risk of of doing
something because the regulations will
change
um along the way and that they
really are not helpful is that an issue
in your view
it's an issue in in in in my view um i
think one thing that we haven't
and it's my fault that we haven't talked
about
but what now has happened after 20 years
because that trend started and you
talked about the department of finance
so
around 96 we change right the the policy
framework for innovation and invention
and research uh mainly lynch
uh speaking about being the oecd
darlings and we decided to move and
spend a huge amount of money on our
research infrastructure in universities
not on industrial research right and
then we created this
a tax system that
mainstream economics would love right
it's exactly what you should do
which supposedly was to create demand
for whatever
we spun out of universities both human
like human capital
labor sophisticated labor and those
invention
that doesn't work right
i mean the proof is in the public but
now we have a serious problem that
nobody talks about so i wanted to
mention it
we have an research infrastructure which
is in the top of a world and you can see
who actually wants to work with it and
the business which is about here
so assuming that most of our businesses
especially when we don't have motel we
don't really have bombardier we don't
have blackberry and we can go on and on
and on can actually engage
with the outcome the great inventions
that are coming
is ridiculous
so one of the things that needs to be
done now
speaking about the business sector is
somehow
using whatever powers we have and if
anyone is going to tell as you know
david is anyone going to tell you i have
this one solution it's one program and
will solve all your it's he or she is
either delusional
or just lying
we really and that's a problem of
innovation policy it's experimental we
don't really know what will work right
we need to to try and especially when
we're stuck in this equilibrium
using everything that we can
figure out what start to move a needle
scale it up figure out what doesn't work
for 30 years and scale it down
we have not done that
um
worse
and then i'll stop
when you have this wonderful
research infrastructure in a global
system there is no vacuum so the people
who then or organization then take this
innovation and makes unbelievable amount
of money jobs and all the rest out of it
are
our companies just not canadian
companies
and we
at the moment just don't have apart from
what i will call the startup
scene which is actually growing and and
i think i said it somewhere else it's a
beam of light but it's small
we don't have in any of those things
from agriculture and forestry even if
you and i would go to all the canadian
leaders in forestry and they'll say you
know what david nani you're right we
really want to innovate we really want
to go to the universities
they don't have the skills the routines
the people to actually be
able to engage with a research currently
happening with canadian universities and
that's something that we have to fix
and i
am wondering i don't know but i'm
wondering whether this is even more
important than regulatory
on the regulatory um and i know i'm
taking stealing a lot of time so i'll
try to be short there's two problem with
regulation
one if i'm an innovator
and i even managed to do the r d i even
managed to come up with a new product
and service i put it on the market i
face two uncertainties
new uncertainties one maybe customers
wouldn't like it
but worse customers might actually love
it but then the government will come and
say hey hey stop you're not allowed to
sell it
and in canada unlike the united states
we are we have that risk
uh constantly and in finance
until very recently it was almost
impossible in a way this has boom of
fintech
and you look at the especially in the
early days the first 10 years what were
the only two areas in which fintech
companies made money
and those are the two areas in which it
was not legal for canadian company to
offer services which was currency
exchange and you know those loan clubs
that you know cost consumers
come together to give loans to
businesses and ideas
canadian companies were not allowed to
compete
so immediately
by regulation we decided that our
entrepreneurs either have to leave a
country
or figure out ways to compete unevenly
with everest
guess what happened our best
entrepreneurs left the country
you come back to
the business having the people to absorb
uh absorb and implement or take to to
the commercial stage some of the ideas
that are being generated by our uh very
very
active uh
active uh
academic uh
and uh research uh program
um how do you
what what do you think that
governments can do federal and
provincial because
provinces are very important in this
regard
very important
in a negative way as you mentioned
blocking up
having a national
common market
but
what
what is it that
we could actually do what governments
could actually do
to help foster
uh that ecosystem
that is required uh
going forward
so
i i can tell you what other governments
have done quite successfully
so first of all
by using you know i'm in finance i'm
going to talk about finance
uh by using finite direct financial
incentives unlike indirect tax
incentives and you can see more and more
research but unfortunately not enough
but you can see more and more research
that the result on the ground of which
countries actually became more
innovative in which not actually in her
direct grants and loans
for various technical reasons but partly
because they actually lower uncertainty
before you make your decision whether to
r d
are much more effective
in encouraging more r d
especially in companies that have not
engaged with r d before so they're
afraid
so one of the things that we should do
and we have sort of been doing but
without admitting it in the last six to
ten years we have moved more and more
money to a constellation of programs
that's our main
goal is to give direct assistance
we should rationalize that we should
make it a lot easier because the other
thing that has happened
and again if you look at research and
results is where this has been done very
efficiently very quickly so countries
where if you come up with an idea for an
r d project for a new product and they
give you a yes or no answer in 10 weeks
companies
their impact on r d is much higher in
countries where you go to a program and
then you have to haggle with them for
over a year or even just six months
by that time
you say you know what forget it i don't
want this r d i'll continue to do
business as usual
um the second is and we talked about it
before is coordination a lot of those
problems
and especially when you want to move a
whole industry
toward an r d trajectory or innovative
trajectory
part of what
governments can do and business find it
very difficult to do is to coordinate a
collective action
not necessarily decide what the
collective action is
but to create and enable collective
action
moving toward r d
deciding for example
what should be this i mean the business
should decide what should be the set of
technologies and products that might
enable
we constantly use forestry so i'll just
keep it there our forestry industry to
move up and then
enabling it either through
finance evil through recreating of
organizations
um
figuring out we spoke about regulation
it's really nice and and i've played
this game right
going to government say you're horrible
our regulation is really awful it's much
much much much harder
to answer government and it happens both
provincial and and the federal said okay
we agree so tell us how to change
government where we should change
regulation toward what regulation how
does that impaired
uh
again you need collective action and
working with business so information can
flow in both ways
uh and i can go on and on but i feel i
constantly talk and i don't give you
enough time to talk so i'll shut up for
a moment
no no you're you're the outsider that
we as officials bring in at finance to
uh to try
to try spur the ideas
but i i i go back to to this issue of
of
what it is
uh that governments can do to create
that ecosystem
and
your answer it sounded to me is well the
government should give
some more upfront grants
to allow business to get on
and be willing and be willing to write
off
six or seven or eight out of ten of
those
um because
innovation we know the root of
innovation is that you fail along the
way
uh and we have to be
willing government has to be willing to
countenance
failure
when they when they do those things
and we have difficulty i think in this
country countenance countenancing
failures so
so
we've got this very sketch
in the budget of
some sort of new agency
um i mean the politicians love to create
a new agency rather than to make
whatever is there work
but
we've got this sketch for it what is it
that that's going to do
differently
than we had in mind for the canada
investment bank in order to facilitate
uh things there or
that we had in mind in our so-called
clusters uh program
what what is going to be different about
this new
you know bobble on the christmas tree of
programs the government has
uh that's really going to uh do
something
so let's start first of all it's not a
program
and and and by the way this government
i don't know how happy they were to
create new agencies
or even repurpose old
but they loved programs and we just
discussed that a program even an
extremely successful program let's just
assume
let's not talk about details let's just
assume the supercluster would do
everything that they promised in five
years that's not going to change your
whole system
okay so the one thing that this agency
is supposed to do
is to deal with that problem
and deal with that problem speaking
about the canadian investment bank and
other programs that this government and
other had
not just in a budget by budget cycle
but be able to say this is a systematic
problem and we are focused on a very
simple mission which is
enhancing you want to call it maximizing
private business r d leading to exports
this is just one example of such mission
over the years over political cycle over
budget cycles because part of a part of
other thing of lowering uncertainty is
business need to know for those programs
takes about three years for businesses
to actually figure out how to work with
new programs
and if your program is three to five
years by the time businesses even learn
how to use it it's shut down
creating that agency as independent
agency
so they can do what they need to do and
we'll talk about it that way also create
a certainty and business know that they
have a partner
the fact also that this agency is going
to be independent
meaning
that it is not
it is able if if we do it right to
actually experiment and fail
not 90 because i don't think anything
done with public money should 90
i'm not even sure about 60 70 but 50
but being able to fail and even more so
in the canadian content actually
admit that it's failing and then
changing saying this program we really
try to do i don't know mini clusters
it's a complete failure
with shutting it down moving the money
trying something else
that's nothing we have in the machinery
of government right now
it's nothing that you can do in a
political cycle or under a politician
because it will hurt their chances of
getting re-election
you need to create a buffer
that would allow you to experiment and
fail you also need to create
organization doing innovation policy
right in any other country but canada is
considered a profession
it's considered something that you have
to learn it's considered something that
you have to bring expertise it's
considered something that you have to
have business people involved with in a
constant dialogue sometime taking the
helm as a ceo of agency
we in 96 decided that we are not
interested in having those kinds of
skills
either in business or in the civil
service
this is the first time that at least we
admit we made a mistake and we want to
rebuild those skills and give them
the shield what i call independence so
they can do experiment failure try try
again until something works and that's
the big difference
so continuity
uh
continuity and
and
willing willingness to
to take uh to take risks uh to put that
money out now
that that
that inevitable that sounds
let me put it differently that sounds
very sensible
uh
whether
whether it's it
in itself is enough is another question
uh but it at least it sounds very
sensible
uh so if we were to create this pot uh
this what she had in the budget as a as
a growth fund that is there that we're
going to turn off to
this uh
group of wise people uh
not a wise people of of very uh
dynamic innovative people
turn turn that to them
and suppose the government says yeah
we're willing we're willing
to
tax everybody
10 billion dollars a year to create this
or 15 million dollars a year
to create this
um then
what what is going to be the metric
that is going to allow a government
three or five or seven years from now
to turn around and say look we've been
able to measure the effectiveness of
this
spending our 10 or 15 billion dollars on
that rather than on
some social programs or something that
or
quite frankly
investing in housing where the
government has just decided to spend 10
billion bucks over five bit years on
something that is not going to create
one
innovate one bit of innovation
um
in uh
in industry
so
what are the metrics that are going to
allow us to say this sort of thing
uh
can can be successful how are we going
to continue to judge it over time so
that there continues to be
political support for allocating this
amount of dough
to do what you are asking for
so i again
since we haven't made that decision
right if you look at the budget we're
now supposed to start a conservation
program
what i'm saying now is
my ideas not necessarily what the
government will do okay let's just i
want to make it clear
looking and what i'm going to say now
and i've been looking and i've been
looking for a while um on other
countries
and i would say that the simplest the
simplest metrics
work the best and the simple matrix that
i have seen and again
you know there's multiple beautiful
words around them but basically it's a
consistent growth of bird
right
so you measure whether or not
canadian businesses
all canadian business both services and
industry uh are
in investing more in r d
that's one thing you measure
and the other thing you measure and i
think this is extremely important
speaking about market discipline
is whether that leads all those money
and all those because you have a list of
all the projects that you gave money to
leads to more exports
not to more sales in canada
but to more exports
because that's way that you know that
you really are competing with the best
and it has nothing to do with whoever
may be
in canada and that's a different talk
you and i should have david we have a
slightly too protective market that
create concentration and oligopoly in
critical sectors but i don't think we
have another 45 minutes to talk about
that but maybe we should uh but those
are the two metrics that i would like to
see
and if you want to add the creations of
new companies uh the number of new
products and services offered by
canadian companies
um
tfp total factor productivity which
means that canadian business starts not
only engage more with technology but
actually using us canadian highly
educated canadian better so our
productivity goals so productivity
measures
those are great
but it needs to be simple and constant
and the one thing that i would highly
advise not to do is just counting jobs
because then we will end up
where where we are today which is it's
much easier to give tesla a huge amount
of money to open a battery factory
than trying to figure out
uh how many jobs
17
startups might or might not create
so we have a couple minutes left um i
would love to sneak in at least one or
two questions uh from the audience
although i have to say you've touched on
many of them already through the
conversation um
there's a question here that's asking
about our unique geography in canada um
and our our neighbors to the south
wondering um whether there's any kind of
unique border effect so
this person is asking how can we work to
address the effect of u.s capital pull
trade prioritization talent flow
cultural influence etc um and and
wonders whether this might also be part
of the either problem or solution
so um i'll start with with a
unique window of opportunity that i
think we have now
the whole world for both uh after covet
but also for geopolitical reasons have
realized that the way our globalization
work doesn't really work we're not going
to retreat from globalization but
actively
leading countries are reconfiguring what
i call the regional supply networks
the americans are doing it
and they're making decisions where to
put various activities
in what they see is north america and
they think america first
but it's an opening
in all industries including where we're
good at which is the resource industries
if we don't engage with them and come
with a plan for ourselves and then
convince the american to work with us
americans will make that decision for us
um so i would urge us
to actually come up with a plan
the second
the pool is both good and bad
um it's going to be there it's going to
give us a great opportunity
it's actually giving us a very small and
diverse economy
a massive market that if we get
something right the most sophisticated
but also richest market in the world is
us overtaking
and and it's very easy to do that
the flip side of it is that it's also
easy to just move to that market
we need to play on our strengths and
it's much nicer unless you know that
you're a billionaire to be a canadian
it's a much just and fair economy
our education system is better and we
can go on and on and on
all of those things are cool things if
we make it easier for people who
actually want to grow a business and
help our community to do so
most people would prefer to be a
canadian maybe they will want a house in
florida for two months in the winter but
they will prefer to be canadian and to
have their children grow in canada
we need to play on those strengths
well
and we need we need to make
uh
because my work i mean we've been
working on this and now we have to make
it work
uh and
that is not going to be quite as easy
damn as i think that you uh you assume
but yes
uh that's what we need to do
and
we have to find a way
we have to find a way and this is the
political trick
uh to make jobs
we've always used the words growth in
jobs
in fact jobs were the primary measure
what we really need to make the measure
is is growth
and that's where we've been failing and
that we have to find
a way to dress up
this word growth in something that
resonates with the ordinary citizen so
that we can do
what you've just talked about and that
is to support
the ecosystems
that are going to give us give us that
growth uh going forward
yep and i never like to tackle easy
problems
and i always like to think in decades so
i'm okay
all right um unfortunately we are all
out of time there are some terrific
questions that have come in uh dan we
might ask you to answer some and we can
post them online alongside the video
which will be available in about a
week's time uh dan david again thank you
so much for your time this morning
thanks everyone for joining and we look
forward to the next conversation
thank you rachel
[Music]
you